pour la russie la nouvelle aide
financière de washington pour la
sécurité de kiev constitue une menace
imminente mais moscou veut privilégier
une résolution pacifique et diplomatique
pour plus de précisions on retrouve
notre correspondante verhaeghe hoffman
la russie se dit une nouvelle fois
contrainte à démentir de nouvelles
accusations relatives aux intentions
qu'elle entretiendrait d'envoyer
l'ukraine cette fois c'est l'ambassadeur
russe aux états unis qui réagissait aux
déclarations des hauts responsables de
la maison blanche du département d'état
et du pentagone qui évoquait à l'absence
de mesures de désescalade à la frontière
russo ukrainienne est suggéré que la
russie pouvait envahir l'ukraine à tout
moment y compris depuis le territoire de
la biélorussie et en ce qui concerne la
désescalade souhaité l'ambassade russe a
notamment appelé les états unis à cesser
de fournir des armes à l'ukraine est
arrêté d'inciter les autorités
ukrainiennes a multiplié les
provocations militaires dans l'est du
pays écoutez
nous soulignons encore une fois la
russie n'a pas l'intention d'attaquer
qui que se soit déplacé des troupes sur
notre propre sol relève de notre droit
souverain nous appelons à mettre fin à
l'hystérie et à ne pas aggraver les
tensions autour du problème du donbass
et surtout à ne pas encourager les têtes
brûlées à kiev à recourir à de nouvelles
provocations
si les états unis sont vraiment engagés
dans des efforts diplomatiques pour
résoudre le conflit interne ukrainien il
devrait abandonner leur projet de
fourniture de nouvelles cargaisons
d'armes aux forces armées ukrainiennes
au lieu de cela ou ashington devrait
user de son influence auprès des
autorités ukrainiennes pour les
convaincre de cesser de saboter les
accords de minsk le ministère ukrainien
de la défense a quant à lui affirmé le
18 janvier que cinq ago britanniques ont
fourni des systèmes de missile nlo
l'équivalent déjà velin américain
destiné à détruire des chats des
véhicules militaires selon le chef de la
république populaire autoproclamé de
donetsk dennis pouchet line la situation
sur place dans l'est de l'ukraine est
plus que tendue et les vauclin
militaires et armes américain et
canadien dans la région écouter
l'otan s'approchent des frontières de la
russie de plus en plus d'armes sont
apportées sur le territoire ukrainien
des instructeurs arrive des états unis
du canada l'ukraine déplace une énorme
quantité d'équipement militaire et de
personnel vers la ligne de contact la
mobilisation de bataillons de
volontaires et a été annoncé l'ukraine
utilise des drones de combat y compris
des drones assez dangereux je parle de
bayraktar tv2 mais néanmoins on dit que
c'est le dombass ou la russie qui
prépare une nouvelle fois quelque chose
nous y sommes habitués mais actuellement
les combats ont déjà lieu au niveau
géopolitique
parfois cela devrait se terminer on ne
le sait pas non plus tout le monde se
trouve sous une pression assez sérieuse
la russie salue les efforts de tous les
pays en matière du règlement de la
situation en ukraine a déclaré le porte
parole du kremlin mais très peskov et là
souligné que l'essentiel était le
respect des accords de minsk
évidemment nous saluons les efforts de
tous les pays visant à nous aider à
régler la situation en ukraine les
divergences fondamentales entre la
russie et l'ukraine sont liés
précisément au fait que la partie
ukrainienne fait traîner la mise en
oeuvre des accords de minsk
si nos partenaires turcs peuvent
influencer la partie ukrainienne lui
faire respecter ses engagements et ses
obligations prix nous ne pouvons que le
saluer le lieu de tels contacts a une
importance secondaire
l'essentiel c'est d'influencé l'ukraine
selon dmitri peskov la situation en
ukraine est extrêmement tendue on
constate que des armes ils sont livrés
des diverses manoeuvres de l'otan et des
pays de l'europe occidentale sont
effectués pour le crémant tout cela
engendre des tensions autour d'eux le
crâne